my breath and my when i've seen chicago
has the strongest
as far as just comedy and jokes
like a lot of guys you haven't heard of
like well that's really good
atlanta i think music bits i think if
you're on the show in atlanta at a
comedy club
who's ever gone before if you got two or
three guys going for you
somebody's doing some music bits trust
me
but here's what i do i don't come out i
say if you try to close with a music bit
and i've learned this over time
and then try to bring me right up i'll
wait a minute
two minutes i'll just sit in the green
room and they'll walk in there yeah
you're up like i know i'll be up in a
minute
i'm gonna let that audience breathe yeah
you know what i mean
that's yeah that's that's smart yeah
it's letting the audience like you said
following sandler and then letting the
audience pick up on your pace i think a
lot of younger comics
try to match the pace of the comic
before them
but yeah and acknowledge it acknowledge
the i acknowledge like sandler i go boy
i know you guys are
thought who i i said something like i
bet you felt like jim carrey was next
because this [__] kept going up and up
i go nope and i said i i even said i'm
really famous of black people
and we only have two mixed people here
tonight and there was like two mixed
girls in the audience i go
fine i got one fan here hello
you gotta acknowledge what's going on
around you you know but that comes with
with time don't try to just go like oh
this is my best joke i'm gonna hit it
but i think you're right we try to match
the energy
instead of like letting audience take a
breath take a breath